gentlemen welcome we are here today to
talk about why the [ __ ] aren't Asian men
considered sexy usually for left and
that's all I'm just setting the tone for
this conversation
the idea that Asian men in American
media are emasculated and seen as
somehow less than than other racial
counterparts is something that's been
historically sort of plaguing a lot of
the different projects that we've all
probably worked on in the past why do
you think Asian men are considered sexy
it's the result of effectively a
historical campaign I mean you know
Asian immigrants first started coming to
this country
everything from political cartoons
obviously government policy was all
about confirming Asians as as almost
bestial vermin and you know when were
were kind of pushed in one direction and
sort of over sexualized exotic and men
meanwhile were pushed into this corner
of neutered eunuchs you know with tiny
bodies and our barrack it's like the
opposite of what was purported as like
the Western ideal of gender norms right
Asian characters we'd never think of
them as anything but at best up until
like maybe I think in the last 5-10
years the friend I mean it's interesting
though even like the Nazca lines roles
like the you know say martial artists
and so on and so forth they're still
kind of not getting any you know it's
like icily at the end of Romeo Must Die
they had a good long handshake and
because Asian men have sex by really
prolonged handshakes
there's a really interesting valley
we're discussing where the two peaks for
Asia male tracked in this these days is
like really strong Bureau masculinity or
really specifically designed femininity
but this valley of what we would I call
in a layman's way the average
asian-american male is never really
spoken to and what's interesting is I
feel like the average male in other
cultures specifically let's say with
white American culture is constantly
spoken to like the idea of being an
average Joe is literally almost a badge
of honor you even see more diversity of
size and shape and so forth among
African Hispanic actors at least in
comedies right if you are an Asian lead
you have
almost have to be super hot which one
that when that trickles down what does
it say for the young asian-american male
who's considered more average-looking it
automatically makes you subpar to the
national average outside of your race
like people talk about kpop as if it's
going to save the world right like Asian
idols from Asia are going to make it all
good for the rest of us and the fact is
as much as I appreciate that it's kind
of cool that it's being imported here
it's again one of those things which
doesn't quite solve it for just everyday
Asian guys in the middle of America
India doing well and like all these
macho Abhishek Bachchan's and John
Abraham who are like the Tom Cruise's
and Brad Pitt's of India
it still has nothing to do with my life
yes we have unicorns you know what I
mean it's like they're genetically
gifted people every ethnic uestion about
that but it doesn't adjust the larger
reality that we live in a culture in
which the basic standards and you know
not the one that we can aspire to not
the ones that if we you know Jim ratted
all of our lives and we're born with
right parents and all that stuff
whatever like the basic standards what
an asian guy looks like probably falls
short in different ways you never ever
get to see these images and media of
like an Asian guy you grew up with or
your brother or your father with media
in this country because it has been
predominantly white and I get like you
know I'm sure like some people are like
stop talking about not being white but
when you're not the majority in it you
have to have that visibility just so you
can show people like it's not the only
option if you like that great but like
it can't be the only thing you see if I
tell you and I'm gonna party I'm like oh
I want you my girlfriend to meet my
friend he's a he's a white guy what'd he
look like
oh he's you know brunette and he's like
a little husky but he's really funny and
they'll be like oh yeah sure he'll meet
him and then I'm like oh you want to be
my here's my Chinese friend he's coming
he's you know he's kind of you know he's
like black hair and a little husky
they'd be like is so true true everyone
that was gotten that people might say
well here's the old argument of it's a
preference it's not like racism and the
whole thing is it comes down to if you
walk into any situation and just because
someone's of a certain ethnicity you
have a lower opinion of
that starts spreading in its own way to
things that actually have like I think a
lot of dire consequences every time I
hear the term preference brought up in
any kind of conversation it always feels
like it's a danger signal that
somebody's about to like say stuff
that's [ __ ] and that's because the
assumption is that there's some sort of
level level playing field right so in
say casting movies it's like oh well you
know we're casting for talent we're not
really looking for people of a certain
color or high or shape whatever but then
why always picking the six-foot tall
white guys you know first like silent
films in Hollywood you have anime Wong
and sessue hayakawa yes Hayakawa's who
was like the first real like Japanese
Asian male idol was lusted over by
American women but then there's so much
that comes into the propaganda of
politics and media that shifted public
perception of men cuz at some point
right he couldn't get work anymore in
Hollywood films that had to go to Europe
there's also pre-world War two
you know and then we were worried about
everyone was Japanese and plotting
against us and then the Korean War and
then the Vietnamese War and everything
was like this this is not that long ago
though that's the thing people forget
this is what our parents went through
the reality is this we are gonna live
hopefully in a world which is gonna
continually get closer together and in a
country which is gonna get more and more
diverse there are enough of us all
different that if we just learn from
other whether online or off things will
get better on their own and maybe
whether or not we as Asian men get dates
is not a very big piece of what just
looks like but what it is is it's part
of a much larger a set of changes and
for that I'm proud that we're at least
just having this conversation yeah what
I really encourage especially a lot of
viewers out there is to not be as
reactive like everyone is but be more
responsive like if you see something
where you want to see more Asian
American men and media sometimes it's
not just the actors you have to find out
who the executive producers are on a
project you to find out who's the writer
like there's so many different things
that play that shape the idea of what's
being told to young people in
entertainment and politics and media
that you can't just Center on
the image of someone yeah it's not gonna
be a whole writers room of white men
working on a bt show they can obviously
lend themselves to the experience but it
can't be everyone it can't be all we are
given an opportunity now is just as
Asian men in western media to say we can
be hot any one of us can feel and
express ourselves in a sexual way and
it's not weird and it's not a gimmick
it's just who we are
[Music]
[Music]